plenty of young players in the nfl that
we don't know as well now as we will
come january breakout star candidates
young players due to become ballers this
year chris sims that is our draft for
today and uh due to a technical error i
will be the one asking you the trivia
question for the second straight day are
you ready i'm ready sir yes sir all
right who is the youngest player to ever
catch three touchdown passes in one game
wow the youngest player ever to catch
three touchdown passes in one game holy
that's what i said yes i had to
reprocess that because i just i have no
freaking clue there that one is a really
tough one okay i'm going to go with rob
gronkowski
that's a much better that's a much
better victory song than what i'm
accustomed to although i've never heard
the victory so damn i'm good yeah
someone said that to you i promise
someone said that to you promise you 100
i promise that was too quick of a pivot
you really you need to you need to at
least go through the machinations you
can't be man this is really difficult
my brain you know what really gave it
away is just the fact that we've talked
about gronk so much today and i know
stats and some of the guys are like oh
he's he's prevalent today let's use
something around gronkowski uh that's
the way all you guys work actually so i
just i'm in the brain of the control
room once again so here i go first pick
damn damn damn there's too many options
okay to choose from here this is where
it's scary and like do you want to defer
no i absolutely do not
this is what i want to ask okay is baker
mayfield qualify for this is he is he
qualified because i just would like to
hear from the judge the russian judge
anybody out there anybody want to tell
me i mean i think i think the jury that
is the american sports fan public will
decide whether or not baker mayfield
counts okay well damn that i'm going
with them i'm gonna i'm gonna roll the
dice on baker mayfield i mean it was a
limited sample size last year certainly
but i just think with the weapons around
him the way that team's orchestrated
freddie kitchens i do believe in his
offense and offensive system and
everything he does i just have a hard
time thinking that baker mayfield won't
inject himself into top five top ten
quarterbacks in all of football i really
don't i'm not concerned with what i saw
last weekend in the preseason game
number three again the stats won't look
good but it was just barely off the guy
is just too special of a player too
special the leader understands how to
play the position can do everything as
far as throwing the football can throw
it can be a passer he does everything
really well so i'm going to go with him
to become one of the ballers of the nfl
this year
yeah i i don't know that i would have
gone baker mayfield i think he already
has declared himself but again the court
of public opinion
okay i'm i'm gonna flip it over to the
other side of the ball and this is a guy
who could have been a member of the
browns i would submit should have been
and should be a member of the browns and
how much scary that defense would be all
due respect to denzel ward but it was
set up for the browns to take bradley
chubb with the fourth overall pick in
the draft last year they passed on him
and that ended any conversation about
the broncos trading down because they
were thinking about trading down with
the bills so the bills could get josh
allen in that spot nope give me bradley
chubb and yes he had 12 sacks last year
yes he came within a sack or two of the
rookie record set by the true freak
jermaine curse in 1999 but
bradley chubb
is going to enter this year the khalil
mack aaron donald conversation that
we're going to be talking about him the
way we talk about them by the time
january rolls around that's why i picked
bradley chu okay i i see he was on my i
might have taken him first too but i
think i already looked at him as like a
baller at least he started all the games
so baker mayfield if you're questioning
that then damn i'm questioning bradley
chubb okay i don't know about that one
there i think he's already hit baller
status i almost even thought about miles
garrett too because i think miles
garrett's gonna enter that conversation
as well but i feel like he is baller-ish
already could you imagine if they had
both of those guys miles garrett and
bradley chubb yes i cannot imagine i
mean that would be scary it really would
be because i think miles garrett has the
type of talent to be right there like
you're saying aaron donald khalil mack
like take over the league kind of guy so
good pick i'm with you questionable if
he's not a baller already but i'll go
with it all right listen you went baker
mayfield you opened the door you opened
the door i know i'm still gonna give you
a hard time the hell with you okay here
we go gosh there's so many damn good
ones all right i'm gonna go with one
that this is a little off the radar evan
ingram new york giants that's who i'm
gonna go with evan ingram is a first
round pick uh a few years back he is one
of those hybrid tight ends you know
blocks okay he he can do you know an
okay he's willing to do it but really
he's a receiver and he's special that
way and i just think without odell
beckham jr there and then in the patch
shermer offense that loves you know play
action pass oh the linebackers run up to
take saquon barkley oh no evan ingram's
behind us for you know 15 yards and then
what he can do with the ball in his hand
he's a special special athlete i think
he blows up on the scene this year and
becomes one of the stars of the league
at the tight end position
yeah i i just
with eli manning at quarterback i i just
i don't know and with odell beckham jr
gone
i i don't know
how he gets the openings and the
mismatches that he would get if they had
an outside threat that commands double
coverage all the time i need to run the
ball that's for sure
i i didn't put him on my list i thought
about him i didn't put him on my list uh
for that very reason all right um
okay saquon barkley's already a star
right yes
neither of us with a straight face would
put him on that line no we cannot but
but another guy who was a rookie last
year at the running back position
yes
you're gonna let me take nick chubb i
thought i was gonna take care of i'm
gonna take carry on john either ones
works yeah they're good ones i agree
carry on johnson i mean because you see
what the lions are doing they're
shifting toward that old school
stop the run run the ball stop the run
run the ball and carry on johnson
and they've craved a great running back
in the 20 years since barry sanders
retired and it's all lining up for
johnson to have a great great season
which i thought about chubbing this spot
but i just don't know because you've got
odell beckham jr david and joku jarvis
landry baker mayfield's gonna want to
throw the ball and then kareem hunt's
coming back after eight games yeah and
remember last year oh nick chubb's great
nick chubb's great when the hell are you
going to use nick chubb so i i just i
worry that he's not going to get the
reps and the opportunities to become a
baller i think carrion johnson will i'm
with you i love carrion johnson coming
out of auburn i mean if anybody looked
back at my draft stuff then i mean i was
all over that i love him too mike i'm
with you i think that offensive line is
the real deal there in detroit you're
right they want to change the way they
play football daryl bevel being there
and he was a stud last year and you
could tell he's a stud by just the way
they treat him in pre-season he's kind
of got the bubble wrap on as i go here
get out there and get warm and then as
soon as like they feel like okay he got
warm let's get him out because we're
screwed if he's not on the field i mean
that's the kind of player he's come so
he was on my list there too i'm i'm with
you i'm i'm all over that with you on
that one okay this is where it gets
interesting all right i'm really torn
between two players here
and i'll be transparent with you it's dj
moore and carolina and calvin ridley of
the atlanta falcons both of those guys i
think are looking to be superstars i
think i'm going to go with calvin ridley
uh over dj moore even though i love dj
moore but calvin ridley i you know again
a guy that had 800 yards receiving last
year i think he's clearly going to
establish himself as number two behind
julio jones he's going to see of course
a lot of favorable matchups because most
people are going to favor covering julio
jones in third down oh let's double team
him let's do that calvin ridley will
reap the benefits of that and from what
i've seen in the preseason and inside
info of my brother being down there a
little bit in training camp who's told
me damn this guy is good and not only is
he good he's got the personality of a
superstar and all that too uh i'm gonna
go with calvin ridley kind of taking the
they could have 2 000 yard receivers
this year is what i'm saying i i expect
that to happen
wow and and look at ridley uh worked out
with julio jones in the months before
the draft has learned a lot from
watching him and emulating him and you
know even though he's he may not have
the same physical gifts that jones has
he still has the potential to be a great
receiver so i i i wondered where you
were going when you started rattling off
receivers um
i i uh
yeah it's hard you want to go hey before
i make my pick do you want to go four
rounds sure we can certainly do it today
there's no doubt all right
i'm gonna go marcus davenport
good one mike good one
four and a half sacks last year a guy
they gave up this year's first round
pick to move up to get
in the draft in 2018 didn't do much last
year was hampered by injury but but with
cam jordan there
you go you get an opportunity to have
some favorable match-ups on the other
side and i think davenport could have a
huge year for the saints defense really
good one mike i'm with you there too he
battled injuries all year last year uh
but he's a big physical freak who i
don't think really got to show what his
true colors were all about and i'm with
you i expect this year to him he he's
going to be one of the forces on that
defense on the edge there and uh that's
a good one i did not write that down i
forgot about him so good good by you
all right uh uh you're so rattled you
don't know you're up
you know what i thought maybe
and then do that okay so we're going
let's jam it let's jam it in let's jam
it in okay i like that okay i'm gonna
jam this in then all right vance
mcdonald pittsburgh steelers all right
he's he's 30. i don't care and nobody
knows about him this is a breakout year
where he becomes a baller okay this is
the year first off i think last year he
showed me that he's the most physical
tight end in football not named gronk
with the ball in his hand i mean he
literally runs over people and he's like
he looks like ivan drago i mean he
really does he's like i must break you
but
i think with a no antonio brown there
and that is an offense that knows how to
feature the tight end i think he's going
to get a lot of balls that come his way
and we know big ben can still throw the
ball and i mean look at this highlight
just stiffen arm in people running for
60 yard touchdowns i'm going with vance
mcdonald he's 29. stop ageing the damn
guy
i was exaggerating when i said 30. i had
no idea he's 29.
that confirms my point how is he a young
player he's he's the same age andrew
luck is and andrew luck just retired i
had no idea he was that old either i did
not know either my my last pick and we
we talked about this guy not that long
ago i think after the aftermath of that
jaguars preseason game when nick foles
finally played who's he going to throw
the ball to he's going to throw the ball
to ddw okay get ready for d.d westbrook
to break out and become a star best
receiver that is going to be available
to nick foles and nick foles is going to
get in the ball early enough and he's
got those skills where he's going to pop
and and they can they can use him in the
run game they can throw it to him yeah i
don't know how involved will be in the
return game because you get to a point
where you're too important right the
offense to put at risk but dede
westbrook i think this year is going to
be a a guy that
we're all paying attention to and
defenses are going to have to pay extra
attention to because foles is going to
be finding him all the time yes he's got
superstar traits he really does i mean
he can fly he's fearless over the middle
you're right i mean he can get a reverse
and take it around the corner for 70
yards i mean uh it is special you know i
thought about like even robbie anderson
for the jets along those lines you know
that was another one that popped into my
mind um
all apologies to josh allen i only
didn't take him because i had already
taken one quarterback but josh allen for
the buffalo bills was also on my list
but this interesting one i'm going to be
surprised
you're you're pathetic sorry josh allen
so i'll make a song for you josh oh
jackie i'm so sorry
all right we got to take a break yeah
mayfield evan ingram calvin really vance
mcdonald i've got bradley chubb carry on
johnson marcus davenport dd westbrook
we'll be back with more pft live after
this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports